the mission of Spotify is really about
being a great musical companion to
making it more personal it's not going
to be the streaming music experience of
the online music experience it's going
to be your music experience we create
the tools for people to actually swim in
that sea of music data and find the
information that really corresponds to
why they're there quite a while ago
we've made a decision to focus on data
depending on the complexity of the query
it could take a whole day sometimes you
would have to run overnight and being
able to store that and process that has
been a very big challenge moving to
Google's cloud platform enabled us to
take use of the skill that Google can
provide the reality is it's quite hard
to build great data centers and we saw
an opportunity to spend our focus
elsewhere and that was really the driver
into Google's cloud platform with Google
Cloud tools we can rerun the same query
and you might take a few seconds minutes
the less time that we can spend solving
problems that are already solved like
scaling our Hadoop cluster when Google
has already figured out how to scale it
for us the more time and energy we can
spend on turning our data into value and
that's really a game changer for us when
you're talking about a technology like
bigquery when you're talking about data
flow you will feel the Spotify product
evolve making the user experience great
once you break down the data you realize
that there are new ones it's not a
straight forward path it's a mosaic rich
beyond the most popular artists it's a
lot more than that music and transcend
boundaries of language culture if it
moves you then it's there and it's there
forever
you